My name is Navid Abedzadeh.
And I've been working
on the development
of a lossless electron
beam splitter, which
could be ultimately used in
quantum electron microscopy.
So traditionally the way
electron beam splitting
has worked is by passing
a beam of electrons
through a thin crystal.
The periodic atomic
structure of the crystal
would diffract the electron
beam and therefore split it.
The problem with
that is that whenever
there is electron
going through matter,
there is the inevitable losses
due to inelastic scattering
and absorption.
Our approach is to use
a diffractive electron
mirror, which is a
nanofabricated diffraction
grating with a negative
bias applied to it.
So what happens is sinusoidal
potential surfaces form
on top of this
diffraction grating.
And when an electron interacts
with it, two things happen.
First of all, because these
surfaces are negatively biased,
the electron gets reflected.
And secondly, because they
are sinusoidal in shape,
the electron gets diffracted.
And that's where the
splitting happens.
And since we didn't
really go through matter,
all the losses that
I mentioned earlier
are not a part of this design.
So ultimately the hope is to use
this device in quantum electron
microscopy, which is a
novel electron microscopy
technique proposed to allow
for nanometer resolution
imaging of sensitive biological
samples, such as proteins,
without all the damage that's
caused by the electron beam.